استرو
انضم إلي على خشبة المسرح
اليوم ، ويسعدني أن أقدم لكم
نوعًا جديدًا من الروبوتات المنزلية
التي تدمج رؤية الكمبيوتر لبرامج الأجهزة المتقدمة من alexa والذكاء الاصطناعي
بطريقة جديدة تمامًا باستخدام كاميرا Periscope ،
ويمكنني أيضًا توسيع مجال رؤيتي
تقنيًا لبناء هذا  كان المنظار
صعبًا بشكل لا يصدق ولكنه مفيد جدًا إذا
كنت بعيدًا عن المنزل وفازت ببعض
الأشياء أعلى قليلاً مثل التحقق
لمعرفة ما إذا كان الموقد قد تم تركه
عند دمج الروبوت مع Ring
Protect pro ، فستحصل على المزيد الآن
عندما  عندما تكون بعيدًا ، يمكنك استخدامه
للقيام بدوريات استباقية في نشاط التحقيق في منزلك
وإرسال إشعارات إليك
عندما يكتشف شيئًا غير عادي
طوال الوقت ، بينما يكون لديك خيار
حفظ مقاطع الفيديو هذه في حسابك على Ring ،
تعلمنا في وقت مبكر من هذا البرنامج أن
العملاء لا يفعلون ذلك.  نريد فقط alexa على
عجلات
لتحقيق هذه الغاية ، قمنا بتجسيدها
بشخصية فريدة من نوعها خاصة بها من
إضافة العيون إلى الشاشة إلى مجموعة كاملة
من الأصوات ، فالجهاز ينبض بالحياة حقًا ،
أعطيك مثالًا سريعًا على شكل
موسيقى Beatbox الفلكية [الموسيقى]
الفلكية هو جزء من برنامج الإضافات الخاص بنا في اليوم الأول
والذي تم تصميمه
لإحياء أفكارنا الأكثر طموحًا ،
وسيكون متاحًا
بسعر تمهيدي يبلغ 999 دولارًا